my foot sucks yeah i mean it's my foot
[ __ ] sucks
all right but i don't want a 2.5 foot
yeah
right it's an ego it's an ego thing that
we battle with every day
yeah look i want to say
[Laughter]
about thanks intros really really sweet
yeah yeah and
so you're not moroccan not moroccan i'm
jordanian and i'm
egyptian okay oh so that's fancy um is
it
because i've been there yeah yeah well
the great pyramids are fancy
i don't know the geometry of it do you
like the the math yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's sacred geometry
and it's uh it's a beautiful
beautiful beautiful have you been no
i've only when i was a kid
i have a very uh i'm like a very sad boy
and in the background there's a pyramids
and i was just my shoulders were slumped
and that's all i
really have from that from that area
yeah yeah
but can i ask you this about pyramids is
yeah because i'm sure you know yeah
no i know yeah you know they say on the
internet
that the aliens made the pyramids
because
you know i'll be careful because this is
a this is an area i know a lot about
yeah because i guess the slabs right
sure were precisely cut
they're also gigantic they weigh a lot
and people are arguing how do human
beings you know
but where there's a will there's a way
that's what i used to learn in high
school
you know i mean my teacher told me that
once right the ancient alien
uh ancient astronaut theorists i think
have landed on
the fact that they had help you know and
that we still did it
humans did it on on our own right but
they had help from
school we had a schematic they gave us
schematics is that what you're saying i
think they gave us
schematics yeah yeah so these um
egyptians as they say yeah no that's
what they were
yeah yeah yeah well because there was
cleo right
oh lord who the psychic no the the the
the captain of the the president of
egypt cleopatra oh cleopatra they made
movies
yeah yeah fade down who played her
elizabeth elizabeth warner
yeah yeah so elizabeth warren plays
cleopatra so that's how i know about her
yeah so cleopatra right she's the queen
of
right the pharaoh god who was your lover
her lover was uh marc jacobs no she did
have mark anthony
i know but he i knew he was marc jacobs
yeah the handbag maker yeah
no let me find a real um guy
napoleon what don't what are you getting
so aggressive
if you really think it's napoleon yeah
that's wrong this is the end
okay solve your relationship all right
all right i'm sorry
people don't like i was hoping you would
joke around and say marc jacobs no no i
want to be real in his
can you joke around please
it's getting intense
all right so let's go back to the
pyramids okay so cleopatra right
she was in there she was in there but
she didn't move any rocks or boulders
i'm she was just screaming
and those people that probably had you
know thousands
they were were they slaves no you know
what the people working on the pyramids
were lucky to
and then they were happy to have the job
oh they were
20 years to make one of those things and
they were getting paid and then and fed
and they were and they were stoked on it
yeah i don't okay
i feel like they weren't that's what
we're taught in egypt school
oh really yeah because they're thinking
about making another one yeah
so you're from jordan too huh i was born
there mm-hmm
i was born there you're born in jordan
yeah let me start
let me see is do you know where it is
cairo oh my gosh in egypt
oh my god oh i thought egypt was in
cairo
oh my god what cairo is in egypt okay
anxiety bobby
i don't know much i say marc jacobs this
is part of your say marc jacobs this is
i like this
all right all right so you make me feel
good smart
well i want to say though that um you
know i know we're all joking aside
you know i really think that number one
you're a nice guy
number two i find you to be very funny
and talented thank you number three um
you're ageless you seem you same thank
you
when you said that earlier though when i
said i was you didn't like that
explain to me what explain to people
what you said
i said you don't you said i'm i'm 49 i'm
49 that's what you said and then i say
you don't look but you don't look it
that's the best part but then you said
but but cass i don't like that because i
feel it i feel old